I wrote a little song to remind you, Choice Hotels, gets you more of the experiences you value. The Cambria Hotels got it all. A rooftop bar, have a ball. Cocktails up here feel just right. Is Cambrio homemade? Bring a date, your team, or even your mom. Book direct at Choiceotails.com.
我写了一首小歌来提醒你，精选酒店（Choice Hotels）能为你带来更多你所珍视的体验。坎布里亚酒店（Cambria Hotels）应有尽有。屋顶酒吧，尽情狂欢。这里的鸡尾酒恰到好处。坎布里奥是自制的吗？带上约会对象、团队，甚至你的妈妈。请直接在 Choiceotails.com 网站预订。
See you on the roof. Almost everyone lies occasionally. Even if you consider yourself scrupulously honest, you've probably told the occasional fib. But for a small percentage of people, lying isn't something that they do every once in a while. It's a way of life. Researchers have found that while most people tell between zero and two lies per day on average, the most prolific liars might tell five, ten, or even twenty. In recent weeks, the liar most in the news has been new.
回见，屋顶。几乎每个人都会偶尔撒谎。即便你认为自己一丝不苟地诚实，你也可能偶尔说过善意的谎言。但对于极少数人来说，撒谎并不是偶尔为之。而是一种生活方式。研究人员发现，大多数人平均每天说零到两次谎，而最厉害的谎言制造者每天可能会说五次、十次甚至二十次。最近几周，最受新闻关注的谎言制造者是新任
newly elected Representative George Santos, whose long list of career embellishments, deceptions, and outright falsehoods came to light only after he won his seat. Santos appears to have made up college degrees, real estate holdings, even Jewish ancestry, among his many other fabrications. So what drives big liars to lie, and are their motivations different from those other people who lie less frequently? Is pathological lying a mental health disorder? How common is it? And are liars more prevalent in some professions like politics or sales or those unfounded stereotypes? Are there differences in line between men and women, people of different social backgrounds, or among people who consider themselves religious? And finally, how can you
新当选的众议员乔治·桑托斯（George Santos），他那长串的履历美化、欺骗和彻头彻尾的虚假言论，直到他赢得席位后才曝光。桑托斯似乎虚构了大学学位、房地产投资，甚至犹太血统，这只是他众多造假行为中的一部分。那么，是什么驱使这些大话精不断撒谎？他们的动机与那些偶尔撒谎的人有什么不同？病理性撒谎是一种心理健康疾病吗？它有多常见？某些行业（如政治、销售）中的说谎者是否比其他行业更多，还是这只是一种毫无根据的刻板印象？在男性和女性、不同社会背景的人群，或者自认为有宗教信仰的人群之间，说谎行为是否存在差异？最后，你该如何
recognize prolific liars in your life and protect yourself from being duped? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that It examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. The first is Dr. Drew Curtis, an associate professor of psychology and director of the master's and doctoral programs in counseling psychology at Angelo State University in San Angelo, Texas. Dr. Curtis is a licensed clinical psychologist who studies pathological lying and deception, particularly
识别生活中的高产说谎者，并保护自己免受欺骗？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天请到了两位嘉宾。第一位是德鲁·柯蒂斯博士（Dr. Drew Curtis），他是得克萨斯州圣安吉洛市圣安吉洛州立大学的心理学副教授兼咨询心理学硕士和博士项目主任。柯蒂斯博士是一名持证临床心理学家，专门研究病理性撒谎和欺骗行为，尤其是
in the context of therapy and within health care professions, intimate relationships, and parental relationships. Our second guest is Dr. Christian Hart, a professor of psychology and director of the psychological science graduate program at Texas Women's University. He is an experimental psychologist who conducts research primarily on lying and deception.
在治疗情境以及医疗保健行业、亲密关系和父母关系中的表现。我们的第二位嘉宾是克里斯蒂安·哈特博士（Dr. Christian Hart），他是得克萨斯女子大学心理学教授兼心理科学研究生项目主任。他是一名实验心理学家，主要从事关于谎言和欺骗的研究。
He is also the former president and current executive director of the Southwestern Psychological Association. Dr. Curtis and Hart are the co-authors of the book Pathological Lying, Theory, Research, and Parenthood. practice, which was published in November by APA books. They are also writing a book for the general public called Big Liars, What Psychological Science Tells Us About Lying and How You Can Avoid Being
他也是西南心理学会（Southwestern Psychological Association）的前任会长和现任执行董事。柯蒂斯博士和哈特博士是《病理性撒谎：理论、研究与实践》（Pathological Lying: Theory, Research, and Practice）一书的合著者，该书已由 APA 出版社于 11 月出版。他们还在为普通读者撰写一本名为《大话精：心理科学告诉我们关于谎言的真相以及如何避免被骗》（Big Liars, What Psychological Science Tells Us About Lying and How You Can Avoid Being）的书。
Duped, which will be published by APA books later this year. Thank you both for joining me today. It's a great pleasure to be here. Thank you. Thanks for having us. Great. Well, I started the introduction talking about how we all lie sometimes. So what is the difference between someone who just lies occasionally and a pathological liar? Is it just how often they're lying or are the causes and motivations different? Dr. Curtis, you want to take that one? Yeah, absolutely. A lot of our work has really set out to ask that question among people who lie.
Duped，该书将于今年晚些时候由 APA 出版社出版。非常感谢两位今天能来参加我的节目。很高兴能来到这里。谢谢。谢谢你们邀请我们。太好了。好的，我在开场白里谈到了我们所有人有时都会撒谎。那么，偶尔撒谎的人和病理性撒谎者之间有什么区别？这仅仅取决于他们说谎的频率，还是说原因和动机有所不同？柯蒂斯博士，你想回答这个问题吗？是的，当然。我们的大量工作确实旨在探讨撒谎人群中的这个问题。
Is there a clinical population? Is there a group that's different from people who might tell big liars? And essentially, we found and put forth theory and research that suggests there is. And so the criteria for pathological lying is people who tell an excessive, amount of lies, and that impairs their functioning, brings about distress, and poses some kind of risk of danger to themselves or others. Dr. Hart, let me ask you, what about the substance of the lies? When we're talking about a pathological liar, does that person tell different lies from just, you know, your average
是否存在一个临床群体？是否存在一个与会说弥天大谎的人群不同的群体？本质上，我们发现并提出了支持这一假设的理论和研究。因此，病理性撒谎的标准是：人们说谎的频率极高，这损害了他们的功能，带来了痛苦，并对他们自己或他人构成了某种危险。哈特博士，请问谎言的实质呢？当我们谈论病理性撒谎者时，这个人说的谎与你所知道的普通
everyday garden variety liar? Well, there's not a lot of research on that topic. What we can gather from reading through the extensive case literature on pathological liars over the past century is that their lies tend to be somewhat varied. We can find some pretty clear cases where they're lying for some sort of financial motivation or financial gain. But one of the patterns that we tend to see perhaps more than you'd see in your typical everyday form of liar is lies that are aimed at bringing. attention on oneself. And so that's probably the biggest distinction that we see.
日常生活中随处可见的说谎者有什么不同吗？嗯，关于这个课题的研究并不多。通过阅读过去一个世纪关于病理性撒谎的大量案例文献，我们可以收集到的信息是，他们的谎言往往呈现出一定程度的多样性。我们可以发现一些非常明显的案例，他们撒谎是为了某种财务动机或经济利益。但我们倾向于看到的、可能比你在日常常见类型的说谎者中看到的更多的模式之一，是为了
Pathological lying is not at the moment considered a mental health diagnosis, but you have both advocated for it to be added to the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders. Why is that? Why do you want to see that? Well, I think it's got a robust history in clinical psychiatry and psychology, a lot of our work and research on the literature, the most prominent psychiatrist, the times, you know, late 1800s, early 1900s, have well documented the existence of pathological lying. And it's held different names, you know, like pseudologia, fantastica, mythomania. And so it's been well documented and tucked away by what we would say is the most prolific, prominent researchers and clinicians throughout time.
吸引他人注意而进行的谎言。所以这可能是我们看到的最大区别。病理性撒谎目前不被视为心理健康诊断，但你们两人都主张将其添加到《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中。这是为什么？你们为什么希望看到这一点？嗯，我认为它在临床精神病学和心理学领域有着坚实的历史，我们对文献的大量工作和研究表明，那个时代（大约 19 世纪末、20 世纪初）最著名的精神病学家已经充分记录了病理性撒谎的存在。它曾有过不同的名字，比如幻觉性伪谎（pseudologia fantastica）、虚构症（mythomania）。因此，它一直被我们所说的一代又一代最丰富、最突出的研究人员和临床医生很好地记录和归纳。
And so it's been recognized by them early on. And then some zeitgeist, essentially, we've lost it throughout time. And so Chris and I have picked back up the gauntlet to look at this phenomena. Our research has corroborated based on that theory that there is a group of people who they're lying impairs their problems. And they're looking for some kind of treatment or some kind of help. So we've essentially just been very passionate to look at that. And our research has corroborated that it should be recognized as a diagnostic entity. How optimistic are you that you will succeed in getting the diagnosis included?
因此，它在早期就得到了他们的认可。但在某种时代精神的作用下，随着时间的推移，我们基本上失去了它。因此，克里斯和我重新挑起了担子，来研究这一现象。我们的研究在这一理论的基础上证实，确实存在这样一群人，他们的谎言加剧了他们的问题。他们正在寻求某种治疗或某种帮助。因此，我们本质上只是怀着极大的热情来研究这一点。我们的研究证实，它应该被确认为一个诊断实体。你们对成功将这一诊断纳入其中有多乐观？
And what's involved in that? There's a lot involved. And I guess I'm fairly optimistic. You know, the DSM, the American Psychiatric Association, has criteria for what needs to be done when submitting that. and there's task force and many intelligent people working hard to recognize these things that it's not maybe what some of the common public thinks is you just create a label to stigmatize people that it's a pretty lengthy process and you have to show that there's the existence of something that people struggle with and by providing a label there's going to do more benefit
这其中涉及哪些内容？这其中涉及很多内容。我想我还是相当乐观的。你知道，精神病学手册和美国精神病学会对提交该诊断所需完成的工作制定了标准，
than cause harm. And so I think not only our work but work of others before, us have demonstrated that there's more people who truly suffer from this and want help. And anecdotally, we've had people reach out to us via emails saying, hey, I came across your work and I'm willing to travel across several states for treatment. I need help with this or significant other marriage is about to end and desperately need some help and can you help me? And it's unfortunate when we don't label it as a diagnostic entity, you know, at this point we We can't say we can formally call it anything and can't treat you accordingly. And so it would be beneficial then to the person who thinks that they have the disorder,
胜过造成伤害。因此，我认为不仅是我们的工作，还有我们之前其他人的工作，都表明有更多的人真正饱受其苦并寻求帮助。有趣的是，我们曾通过电子邮件收到人们的联系，他们说：“嘿，我偶然看到了你的工作，我愿意跨越好几个州来接受治疗。我需要这方面的帮助，或者我的另一半婚姻即将破裂，我急需一些帮助，你能帮帮我吗？”不幸的是，当我们不将其标记为一个诊断实体时，你知道，在这一点上，我们无法宣称我们可以正式称呼它为什么，也无法对其实施相应的治疗。因此，对于认为自己患有这种疾病的人来说，这将是有益的，
that their insurance, for example, would cover the treatment. That's why we need this, right? That's one of the major reasons. You certainly want some insurance to cover treatment. And then another reason we want to recognize treatment is so researchers can start looking at what are the effective treatments, what are the empirically supported treatments that we can use to help people treat this in the most cost-effective and time-effective manner. Dr. Hart, let me ask you, how common is pathological lying? Do we know what percentage of the
例如他们的保险可以报销治疗费用。这就是我们需要它的原因，对吗？这是主要原因之一。你当然希望某种保险能涵盖治疗费用。我们希望获得治疗认可的另一个原因是，研究人员可以开始研究什么是有效的治疗方法，什么是我们可以用来帮助人们以最具成本效益和时间效益的方式治疗此病的经验支持的治疗方法。哈特博士，请问病理性撒谎有多普遍？我们是否知道
population might qualify as a pathological liar? Yeah, answering that question's been a little problematic. Historically, researchers have looked at it, but they've looked at it within kind of narrow populations, populations that were having, you know, people in juvenile detention facilities and things like that, where obviously you might expect the rates to be considerably higher than the general population. Drew and I conducted a study that we published a few years ago where we tried to look at this. And based on the data we collected, we are showing rates around like 8 to 13 percent. But a big caveat with that is we were collecting data from people,
人口中有多少比例的人可能有资格被归类为病理性撒谎者？是的，回答这个问题一直有点问题。从历史上看，研究人员探讨过这个问题，但他们是在狭隘的人群中探讨的，比如少年拘留所里的人等等，在这些地方，你显然会预料到其发生率明显高于普通人群。德鲁和我几年前发表了一项研究，我们试图探讨这个问题。根据我们收集的数据，我们发现其发生率大约在 8% 到 13% 之间。但其中一个很大的注意事项是，我们是从
on websites where they might have some particular interest in this and might have, be more likely to have a problem with lying. So the more recent data that we've collected that we talk about in our book, I think we would put the rate at somewhere closer to 5%, if not even smaller than that. And one other thing there, you know, without having this as a diagnostic entity labeled, we can't collect some of that data too. So I think it's, you know, chicken or egg, Once we recognize pathological lying in the DSM, then as it's getting diagnosed, we can get more accurate data of what its prevalence is. Now, your book talks about differences in lying based on gender, social status, and some other demographic characteristics. Could you detail what you and other researchers have found in those areas?
一些对这个话题可能有特殊兴趣、并且可能更有可能有说谎问题的网站上收集数据的。因此，我们在书中讨论的最近收集的数据，我想我们会将发生率定在接近 5%，甚至更低。还有一点，你知道，如果没有将此作为诊断实体进行标记，我们就无法收集其中的一些数据。所以我认为这是先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，一旦我们在 DSM 中确认了病理性撒谎，那么随着它的被诊断，我们就可以获得关于其流行程度的更准确数据。现在，你们的书讨论了根据社会地位、性别和其他一些人口统计特征在说谎方面的差异。能否详细说明一下你和其他研究人员在这些领域发现了什么？
Sure. I'll talk a little bit about that. with gender, we don't really see any gender differences in the frequency with which people lie. We do see some differences in the types of things that men and women lie about. For instance, women are more apt to tell lies that are relational in nature, whereas men are more apt to tell more kind of self-serving, selfish lies, I guess it would be the best way to describe them. We see some other traits and characteristics that are associated with more frequent lying. You mentioned religiosity at the beginning of this program. We actually just completed a fairly large study on that topic and didn't find much of a relationship at all between religiosity and lying.
当然。我会谈谈这一点。关于性别，我们在人们说谎的频率上并没有真正看到任何性别差异。但在男女说谎的事物类型上，我们确实看到了一些差异。例如，女性更有可能说与人际关系本质相关的谎言，而男性则更有可能说更具利己主义、自私性质的谎言，我想这是对它们最好的描述。我们发现了一些其他与更频繁说谎相关的特征和特质。你在本节目开始时提到了宗教信仰。我们其实刚刚完成了一项关于该课题的相当大的研究，并没有发现宗教信仰与说谎之间有太多的关联。
Age is probably the biggest factor. If we look at the frequency of lying across the lifespan, lying seems to peak and late adolescence. So it kind of gradually increases throughout childhood peaks and late adolescence and then slowly declines across adulthood. So age is certainly the factor that we've identified so far that seems to be the strongest predictor of lying. Then we also have personality traits.
年龄可能是最大的因素。如果我们观察整个生命周期中说谎的频率，说谎似乎在青少年晚期达到顶峰。它在整个童年时期逐渐增加，在青少年晚期达到顶峰，然后随着成年期缓慢下降。因此，年龄无疑是我们迄今为止确定的、似乎是说谎的最强预测因素的因素。然后我们还有人格特质。
So your listeners are probably familiar with the, dark triad personality traits. You know, all these different malevolent personality traits, those tend to be associated with lying. Looking at kind of big five personality traits, we find that people who are low and agreeableness and high in neuroticism are more likely to lie. And then finally, people who have low self-esteem are much more inclined to lie
所以你们的听众可能对黑暗三人格特质很熟悉。你知道，所有这些不同的恶劣人格特质，往往都与说谎有关。从“大五人格”特质来看，我们发现宜人性较低和神经质较高的人更有可能说谎。最后，自尊心较低的人比自尊心较高的人更有倾向
than those who have higher levels of self-esteem. So I think the research shows, that lying in people starts around age three, right? That's when children first figure out that they can sort of fib to mom and dad. But at what age does pathological lying start? Do you know? Our work has largely suggested the onset, primarily in adolescence, late childhood adolescence. And so one of the studies that Chris and I with Dr. Victoria Tower are currently working on is looking at an adolescent sample to look at some more specific factors of ideology. So looking at executive functioning within that group and looking at the onset.
说谎。所以我想研究表明，人们开始说谎大约在三岁左右，对吧？那是孩子们第一次意识到他们可以向爸爸妈妈撒谎的时候。但是病理性撒谎从什么年龄开始？你们知道吗？我们的大量研究表明，它的发病主要在青春期、儿童晚期到青春期。因此，克里斯和我与维多利亚·托尔博士（Dr. Victoria Tower）目前正在合作的一项研究，就是观察一个青少年样本，以探讨病因的一些更具体因素。因此，观察该群体内的执行功能并观察发病情况。
So digging a little deeper into adolescence. There is a stereotype of dishonest politicians with George Santos being a very extreme example right now, although not the only one, or other types of snake oil salesmen. Is there a kernel of truth to that? Are pathological liars more common in some professions than others? We haven't seen any evidence of that. When we look at lying generally, we see that people tend to lie when they have a motivation or an incentive to lie. And those motivations and incentives are more common in some professions than others, certainly.
因此，对青春期进行更深入的研究。存在一种关于不诚实政客的刻板印象，乔治·桑托斯目前就是一个非常极端的例子，尽管不是唯一的例子，或者其他类型的江湖郎中。这其中包含核心真相吗？病理性撒谎者在某些职业中是否比其他职业更常见？我们没有看到任何这方面的证据。当我们笼统地看待说谎时，我们发现人们往往在有说谎的动机或诱因时才会说谎。这些动机和诱因在某些职业中当然比在其他职业中更常见。
in sales and in politics, it's very difficult to be entirely honest and effectively do one's job. And so taking politics as an example, we can see that people who go into politics don't seem to be any less honest, typically, than people in the general population. However, what we see is that politicians who lie more are much more likely to be reelected. And so what it suggests is that the people who go into politics are probably no less honest than you and me, but there's something about the profession that pushes them in a direction where they might have to conceal certain truths that might cause them to lose some of their favorability with the public and might push them to, to fabricate information and exaggerate and perhaps even conceal the truth and lie. Well, are pathological liars aware that they are lying or do they tend to believe what they're saying? And do they really grasp the consequences of their falsehoods?
在销售和政治领域，要做到完全诚实并有效地完成工作是非常困难的。因此，以政治为例，我们可以看出，从事政治的人似乎并不比普通人群中的人更不诚实。然而，我们看到的是，说谎更多政客更有可能再次当选。因此这表明，投身政治的人可能并不比你我更不诚实，但这个职业的某些方面将他们推向了一个方向，使他们可能不得不隐瞒某些可能导致他们失去公众好感的事实，并可能促使他们编造信息、夸大其词，甚至隐瞒真相并撒谎。好吧，病理性撒谎者是否意识到他们在撒谎，还是他们倾向于相信自己所说的话？他们真的理解他们虚假言论的后果吗？
Our research has indicated. Different research asking about questions of awareness or even some assessment research we've done where we brought people in, conducting psychological evaluations one-on-one. You know, for the definition, let me back up, the definition of lying is an intentional act. So you're intentionally trying to make someone believe something you don't believe to be true. And that definition is important for us because it helps distinguish delusion or aspects of psychopathology of psychosis where someone's delusional where they're actually intending to lie. And so with that awareness, you know, many pathological liars are aware and they are intentionally lying. Now, sometimes, you know, sometimes they may say it's for an innocuous reason or sometimes they may say, I don't know why I said what I said or, you know, someone ask you, what's your favorite cereal and you say weedies even though it's Cheerios? And you're like, well, why'd you lie about that? That's seemingly innocuous. Why would you do that? They may say something like, I'm not sure why I did. And then it, you know,
我们的研究表明。不同的研究询问关于意识的问题，或者我们做过的一些评估研究，我们把人带进来，一对一地进行心理评估。你知道，为了给出定义，让我退一步讲，说谎的定义是一种蓄意行为。所以你是故意想让别人相信一件你认为不是真的事情。这个定义对我们很重要，因为它有助于区分妄想或精神病理学的精神病方面，在这些方面，某人有妄想，他们实际上是打算说谎的。因此，凭借这种意识，你知道，许多病理性撒谎者是有意识的，他们是在故意撒谎。现在，有时，你知道，有时他们可能会说这是出于无害的原因，或者有时他们可能会说，我不知道我为什么说我刚才说的话，或者，你知道，有人问你，你最喜欢什么麦片，你说是威笛（Weedies），尽管它是奇瑞欧（Cheerios）？而你会想，嗯，你为什么要为那个撒谎？这似乎是无害的。你为什么要这样做？他们可能会说一些类似于“我不确定我为什么要这么做”的话。然后，你知道，
know, it can build up from that, you know, becoming this monstrous lies to cover lies to cover lies. But many of the times that they are aware and in the moment they'll say doing so almost as a compulsion reduces the anxiety and they feel momentarily relief. But then sometime afterwards, you know, maybe hours, maybe the next day or two, that's where the remorse and the guilt comes in where they're thinking, why did I lie about weedies? Why didn't I just say I like Cheerios or why did I lie about my favorite band or song? Why did I do that? And that's where the guilt and remorse will be present.
它可以从那一点点积累起来，你知道，变成为了掩盖谎言而撒下庞大的谎言，再为了掩盖那些谎言而继续撒谎。但在很多时候，他们是有意识的，并且在当下他们会说这样做几乎是一种强迫行为，可以减轻焦虑，他们会感到短暂的缓解。但在那之后的某个时间，你知道，也许几个小时，也许第二天或两天后，这就是悔恨和内疚产生的地方，他们会想，我为什么要为威笛撒谎？我为什么不直接说我喜欢奇瑞欧，或者我为什么要为我最喜欢的乐队或歌曲撒谎？我为什么要这么做？这就是内疚和悔恨出现的地方。
Are pathological liars more likely to be dishonest in other ways? For example, were they more likely to cheat on their taxes or have extramarital affairs? Or is lying its own thing? And it's just a separate type of dishonesty. That's another area where there's not much research that's been carried out specific on pathological liars that would allow us to answer that question. However, if we look at lying more broadly, what we have found in our research is that if people tend to tell one type of lie or behave dishonestly in one type of way, they tend to lie and be dishonest in other ways as well. And so, for example, we've measured various categories of lies from benevolent white lies to malicious lies to kind of vindictive lies. And what we find is that people who tell a lot of one type of lie tend to tell a lot of the other types of lies as well.
病理性撒谎者是否更有可能在其他方面不诚实？例如，他们是否更有可能逃税或有婚外情？还是说撒谎是它本身的一回事？它只是一种独立类型的不诚实？这是另一个领域，目前还没有针对病理性撒谎者开展太多能够让我们回答这个问题的具体研究。然而，如果我们更广泛地看待说谎，我们在研究中发现的是，如果人们倾向于说某种类型的谎言或以某种类型的方式表现出不诚实，他们往往也会在其他方面说谎和不诚实。因此，例如，我们测量了各种类别的谎言，从善意的善意谎言到恶意的谎言，再到某种报复性的谎言。我们发现的是，说了大量某一种谎言的人，往往也会说大量其他类型的谎言。
So there's these strong correlations between the different types of dishonesty. So what this suggests to us is that for the most part, if we're categorizing someone as being a prolific liar, they're probably going to be lying across domains. However, we also make a point in our upcoming book that some people are deceptive in specific niche areas. And so we're talking about occupations a little bit ago. So someone might be in a position where they find themselves recurrently lying at the workplace, either to deal with a problematic boss or to, you know, sell products to customers or what have you,
因此，不同类型的不诚实之间存在着这些强烈的相关性。所以这向我们表明，在大多数情况下，如果我们把某人归类为高产说谎者，他们很可能会跨领域撒谎。然而，我们在即将出版的书里也指出，有些人是在特定的细分领域具有欺骗性。所以我们刚才讨论了一些职业。因此，某人可能会发现自己处于一种在工作场所经常说谎的位置，要么是为了应对有问题的老板，要么是为了向客户推销产品，诸如此类，
but then might be fairly honest with their family. And so we can have certainly examples of people who have these niche areas where they're prolific liars and honest in other areas. But by and large, dishonest people tend to be dishonest across the different domains of their lives. There's a documentary that just launched on Netflix about Bernie Madoff, you know, who pulled off. The biggest investment Ponzi scheme that we have ever seen, even bigger than the similar scheme we're seeing right now, apparently, by a cryptocurrency dealer, Sam Bankman-Fried. These types of frauds where you rob Peter to pay Paul, as they say, are arguably a form of lying. Would you view people who perpetrate these types of frauds as pathological liars, even though, at least in these cases, these individuals appear to be honest in other areas of their lives? Yeah, I think if we're going to talk about whether they're pathological liars or not, I'll invite your attention back to the way that we've been character.
但对家人可能相当诚实。因此，我们当然可以找到一些人在这些细分领域是高产说谎者而在其他领域诚实的例子。但总体而言，不诚实的人往往在他们生活的各个不同领域都表现得不诚实。Netflix 上刚上映了一部关于伯尼·麦道夫（Bernie Madoff）的纪录片，你知道，他一手策划了
characterizing pathological lying in our book, and the way we characterize it is these are people who prolifically lie, but the lying causes distress and dysfunction in their lives and so forth. And so when we look at people like Bernie Madoff and other scammers and fraudsters, I think it's probably in many cases we're looking at something more along the lines of an anti-social personality disorder rather than what Drew and I would conceptualize. as pathological liars. So these are people who are certainly doing a lot of lying, but their lying is very specific with this malicious intent to manipulate and take advantage of others with this callous disregard, lack of remorse and so forth.
我们见过的最大的投资庞氏骗局，甚至比加密货币交易商萨姆·班克曼-弗里德（Sam Bankman-Fried）目前正在进行的类似骗局还要大。正如人们所说，拆东墙补西墙的这类诈骗可以说是谎言的一种形式。你会将实施这些类型诈骗的人视为病理性撒谎者吗，尽管至少在这些情况下，这些人在生活的其他领域似乎是诚实的？是的，如果我们打算讨论他们是否是病理性撒谎者，我会请大家重新关注我们在书中对病理性撒谎特征的描述方式，
Does pathological lying tend to be a separate disorder, or is it associated with other disorders that have, say, a more formal, recognized diagnosis at this point? Well, that's, you know, that's a great question that many times comes with some clinicians. One of the studies Chris and I did was looking specifically at psychotherapists, looking at licensed psychologist. And, you know, when there is no diagnostic label, what do you do? So we found a number of our research participants who were licensed psychologists indicated they had come across individuals who were pathological liars and they believed them to be pathological liars. And so what they ended up doing was to provide some treatment, needed some
病理性撒谎往往是一个独立的障碍，还是与具有更正式、目前公认诊断的其他障碍有关？嗯，这是一个很多临床医生经常遇到的好问题。我和克里斯做过的一项研究是专门针对心理治疗师、持证心理学家进行的。而且，你知道，当没有诊断标签时，你该怎么办？所以我们发现许多作为研究参与者的持证心理学家表明，他们曾遇到过被认为是病理性撒谎者的人，他们相信这些人就是病理性撒谎者。因此，他们最终做的是为了提供一些治疗，需要一些
diagnostic category. Many times they would give a personality disorder diagnosis. And so that happens. And sometimes, you know, there may be rebuttals or arguments against some of the work Chris and I are doing from others saying, well, that pathological lying is just a symptom of something else like a personality disorder. It's a symptom of antisocial personality. disorder. Some of the work, though, we've done in our lab assessing individuals giving them psychological evaluations, we find that the pathological lying sample, they don't fit the diagnostic criteria for antisocial personality disorder. Many of them haven't had any kind of run-ins with the law or any kind of forensic complications. Many times there's lack of,
诊断类别。很多时候，他们会给出人格障碍的诊断。所以这种情况会发生。有时，你知道，可能会有人对我和克里斯正在做的一些工作提出反驳或争论，他们会说，病理性撒谎只是诸如人格障碍等其他问题的一个症状。它是反社会人格障碍的一个症状。然而，我们在实验室评估个体并给他们进行心理评估时所做的一些工作发现，病理性撒谎样本并不符合反社会人格障碍的诊断标准。他们中的许多人没有任何触犯法律的记录或任何法医方面的并发症。很多时候缺乏
there's no aggression. So aggression is another criteria of anti-social personality. disorder. Many times, as I said earlier, they tend to feel remorse. And so that doesn't fit the same picture as antisocial personality disorder or psychopathy. And so separating that is very important for clinicians. It's also good for people to understand who might be suffering from pathological lying where they line up. And then Charles D.K. from Yale suggested pathological lying as well being considered for the DSM as a diagnostic entity, and under that specifiers of factitious disorder. And so Chris and I, based on our research, would agree with Charles D.K.'s suggesting pathological lying being the overarching diagnosis, and then subtypes and specifiers
攻击性。所以攻击性是反社会人格障碍的另一个标准。正如我刚才所说，很多时候，他们往往会感到悔恨。所以这与反社会人格障碍或精神病态的画像不符。因此，对临床医生来说，将这一点区分开来非常重要。对于可能正在遭受病理性撒谎折磨、想要了解自己处于什么位置的人来说，这也是很好的。此外，来自耶鲁大学的查尔斯·D·K（Charles D.K.）也建议将病理性撒谎作为 DSM 的诊断实体进行考虑，并在其下设立人为障碍（factitious disorder）的说明符。因此，克里斯和我根据我们的研究，会同意查尔斯·D·K 的建议，即以病理性撒谎作为总体诊断，然后设立亚型和说明符，
like factitious disorder or pseudologia fantastica. Are there effective treatments for pathological lying? Can people get better with therapy if they're motivated to do so? And if so, what types of therapy work? Well, as a clinician, I tend to hold an optimistic view of change for people. And so that's where I land. You know, we run in the same problem with, you know, that's a great question. Can people get better? And so we go back to the same problem when we don't have a formal diagnosis. for pathological lying, we don't have research-based treatments to see what is most effective and will these things be helpful. So that poses a problem for us, but in our book, we talk about some research we did with therapists and then our own inferences of treatments. And largely therapists and ourselves, we think that cognitive behavioral therapy would be highly effective
如人为障碍或幻觉性伪谎。病理性撒谎有有效的治疗方法吗？如果人们有治疗的动力，他们能通过治疗好转吗？如果是这样，什么样的治疗有效？嗯，作为一名临床医生，我对人的改变往往抱持乐观的看法。所以我就是这么认为的。你知道，我们遇到了同样的问题，“这是一个好问题。人们能好转吗？”因此，当我们没有针对病理性撒谎的正式诊断时，我们就会回到同一个问题上，
to treat and work with people who suffer from pathological lying. And so essentially what you can do is help people become aware of their cognitions. What's the function of their lives? Which situations might they have a higher proclivity to tell lies? And typically that's going to be relationally. So being aware of those situations. And then a lot of behavioral treatments. So some of these we call differential reinforcement of other behavior.
我们没有基于研究的治疗方法来看看什么是最有效的，以及这些方法是否有帮助。因此，这给我们带来了问题，但在我们的书中，我们讨论了我们对治疗师所做的一些研究以及我们自己对治疗的推断。在很大程度上，治疗师和我们自己都认为认知行为疗法将非常有效，
or habit reversal training. Essentially, the idea is you become aware of your behaviors, become aware of when you lie, and not give that attention, rather reinforce honesty behaviors. And that may mean even when honesty doesn't necessarily lead to a good consequence, you know, if you tell someone that ask you, do you like my new haircut? My son just got a new haircut and he doesn't like it too well. So if you get asked that, you know, you could lie to make someone feel good, oh, it looks great. Or you could be honest and, you know, there's some consequences there. But even with pathological lying, we'd have to reinforce telling the truth, even if the consequence may not be the most desirable for the person. But isn't there kind of a catch-22, though, for the therapist?
用于治疗和帮助遭受病理性撒谎折磨的人。因此，本质上你可以做的是帮助人们意识到他们的认知。他们谎言的功能是什么？他们在哪些情况下更有说谎的倾向？通常情况下，那将是人际关系方面的。因此要意识到这些情况。然后还有许多行为疗法。其中一些我们称之为其他行为的差异强化，
Because you're dealing with somebody whose problem is lying. So how do you know that your patient is telling you the truth? Yeah, that's a great question. and that kind of fueled a lot of Chris and I our interest in this early on, in our work early on and just deception within therapy. So therapy rests on the assumption of honesty, that all that we do and talk therapy is that we assume our patients are honest. One of the things with pathological lying to understand is,
或者习惯逆转训练。本质上，这个想法是让你意识到自己的行为，意识到你什么时候在撒谎，并且不要给予这种关注，而是去强化诚实的行为。这甚至可能意味着，即使诚实并不一定能带来好的结果，你知道，如果你告诉某个询问你的人：“你喜欢我的新发型吗？我儿子刚刚剪了个新发型，他其实不太喜欢。”所以如果你被问到那个问题，你知道，你可以为了让别人感觉良好而撒谎：“哦，看起来好极了。”或者你可以诚实，你知道，这会有一些后果。但即使对于病理性撒谎，我们也必须强化说实话的行为，即使结果可能不是对这个人而言最理想的。但是，对治疗师来说，难道不是存在某种进退维谷的困境吗？
even though they tell lies much more frequently than most people, they're not lying all the time about everything. And so even in some of our assessment studies, the question I would ask people at the end is, what have you lied to me today about? And many of them would indicate nothing. Why not? You know, why haven't you lied? And many of them would say answers like, well, this is a real struggle from me. I'm hoping to advance science. If you learn from me, you can help out other people. So they're not lying all the time about everything. And I think that's important to note. The other thing to note there, too, is I think very important for therapist is when someone lies to us, we typically take it personal and get
因为你面对的是一个问题在于说谎的人。那么你如何知道你的病人对你说的就是实话呢？是的，这是一个很好的问题，这正是我和克里斯早期对这一领域产生兴趣的动力所在，在我们早期的工作以及治疗中的欺骗行为。因此，心理治疗建立在诚实的假设之上，我们在谈话治疗中所做和谈论的一切，都是假设我们的病人是诚实的。关于病理性撒谎，有一点需要理解，
defensive. And that typically isn't productive in therapy. So the way you overcome that is kind of know your stance, become non-defensive, and use that to try to understand with the patient, you know, what's the function of this lie? Are you wanting, are you wanting me to give you praise? are you wanting me to think of you in a certain light? Are you trying to form a certain impression? Do you not want me to think poorly of you?
尽管他们比大多数人更频繁地说谎，但他们并不是对所有事情都在一直撒谎。因此，甚至在我们的一些评估研究中，我在最后要问人们的问题是：“你今天对我撒谎了吗？”他们中的许多人会回答“没有”。为什么不呢？你知道，你为什么没撒谎？他们中的许多人会回答：“这是一场真正的挣扎。我希望推动科学的发展。如果你从我这里了解情况，你就可以帮助其他人。”所以他们并不是对所有事情都在一直撒谎。我认为这一点值得注意。需要注意的另一件事是，我认为对治疗师非常重要的一点是，当有人对我们撒谎时，我们通常会认为这是针对个人的，并表现出
But if you start asking those questions, I think that would breed more trust and compassion for the person to lean in and understand them. And that's why Chris and I really wrote the book we wrote was to lean in and understand pathological lying much deeper rather than just turning away and saying, you know, these are crazies that we can never understand. but people who are suffering and want help.
防御性。这在治疗中通常是没有成效的。克服这一点的方法是了解你的立场，保持非防御性，并尝试与患者一起理解：这个谎言的功能是什么？你是否希望我表扬你？你是否希望我以某种眼光看待你？你是否试图塑造某种印象？你是不是不想让我对你有不好的看法？
What about group therapy as a treatment? Doesn't that give you the option, the opportunity for other people to sort of call out liars as opposed to having the therapist have to do that? Yeah, yeah, we suggest group therapy. And I'm laughing because you're absolutely right. You know, one of the ways that group therapy works is the therapist doesn't have to call out the patient. So the brilliance of any kind of interpersonal work is other members in the group can say, hey, you know, BS, you just lied. And that works so much so well in a group therapy context because it's not about patient client opposing each other. Rather, it's about other people are seeing this thing in you too.
但如果你开始提出这些问题，我认为这将为这个人倾听和理解你建立更多的信任和同理心。这也是为什么克里斯和我真正写了这本书的原因，是为了深入了解病理性撒谎，而不是仅仅转身离开并说：“这些人是我们永远无法理解的疯子”，而是去关注那些正在受苦并寻求帮助的人。
Well, Dr. Hart, let me throw this one at you. How can people recognize and protect themselves from pathological liars? Are there telltale signs or particular personality traits of the most hardened pathological lies? I think we know that we're very bad at telling when people are lying to us. And pathological liars, I mean, how do we suss them out as opposed to just an everyday liar? Yeah, it's a perplexing problem. And you're correct, people are really poor lie detectors if we look at people's ability to detect when people are lying versus being honest in laboratory studies, what we find is that people perform at only
小组治疗作为一种治疗方法怎么样？难道这不给你提供了一种选择吗？让其他人有机会指出说谎者，而不是让治疗师不得不这样做？是的，是的，我们建议进行小组治疗。我在笑，因为你完全说对了。你知道，小组治疗起作用的方式之一就是治疗师不必当面指出患者的谎言。因此，任何类型的人际交往工作的精妙之处在于，小组中的其他成员可以站出来说：“嘿，你知道吗，你刚才在胡说八道（BS），你撒谎了。”这种方法在小组治疗的语境中非常有效，因为这不涉及患者与客户的对立。相反，这是关于其他人也在你身上看到了这一点。
slightly above chance levels. That is, they'd be almost as effective just flipping a coin, guessing whether someone's, as guessing whether someone's being honest or not. And really kind of gets back to the fact that we are a cooperative species, and so we tend to have what's referred to as a truth default. That is, we just assume people are being honest when they speak. And so we tend not to be on guard for deception. So when we look at how people actually detect lying,
哈特博士，让我把这个问题抛给你。人们如何识别病理性撒谎者并保护自己免受其害？对于那些最顽固的病理性谎言，是否存在明显的迹象或特定的人格特征？我想我们知道，我们非常不擅长分辨别人是否在对我们撒谎。对于病理性撒谎者，我的意思是，我们如何将他们甄别出来，而不是仅仅把他们当作日常的说谎者？是的，这是一个令人困惑的问题。你说得对，如果我们观察实验室研究中人们检测别人何时说谎与诚实的能力，我们会发现人们的表现
it's not by seeing that someone's looking askance or they're, you know, fidgeting with their hands or shuffling their feet, but rather we detect people or lying by hearing them say things that conflict with factual information we actually know. Or we find out they're lying by. by gathering additional information from third parties, or in some cases people just feel guilty and confess. And so when we look at how could we avoid being duped by pathological liars,
只略高于几率水平。也就是说，他们的效果几乎和抛硬币、猜别人是否诚实差不多。这实际上归根于这样一个事实：我们是一个合作的物种，因此我们往往具有所谓的“真相默认值”。也就是说，我们说话时只是假设别人是诚实的。因此我们往往不会对欺骗保持警惕。所以当我们观察人们实际上是如何检测谎言时，
my answer would be it's the same way we avoid being duped by everyone else. And primarily what that is is we are sensitive to signs of trustworthiness. when we meet people, we walk in with usually a fairly trusting attitude, but we only trust people so far. And so, for example, if we know that someone has an incentive to lie to us, an incentive to manipulate us, we're going to be more on guard and more apt to detect their dishonesty. Likewise, if we can rely on people's reputations, if I know nothing about your reputation, I'm going to be a little bit more suspicious of things. you say than if I know you quite well and know you to have a reputation as being an honest person. But generally, when we've talked to people about pathological liars that they have met or known and how they knew those people were lying, what we find is they say that the people say unbelievable
并不是通过看到某人斜眼看人，或者他们在摆弄双手、拖着脚步，而是我们通过听到他们说出与我们实际知道的事实信息相冲突的话来检测人们是否在说谎。或者我们发现他们在撒谎，是通过收集第三方的额外信息，或者在某些情况下，人们只是感到内疚并坦白。因此，当我们探讨如何避免被病理性撒谎者欺骗时，
things, that is, they're making claims that just don't seem likely to have actually happened, or they say things that are inconsistent. And so, for example, you know, you were mentioning the case of George Santos, I believe he indicated his mother died during the 9-11 attacks and then later claimed that she had died, you know, a decade later. And so when we see inconsistency and information, that can be a cue. So really what we're doing is we're looking for coherence. We're looking for proof and we're looking for the reputational status of a person. All of those together can inform. of who we should be suspicious of and maybe who we can be more trusting of.
我的回答是，这与我们避免被其他人欺骗的方式相同。主要的做法是，我们对可信度的迹象保持敏感。当我们遇到其他人时，我们通常会带着相当信任的态度走进去，但我们对人的信任是有限度的。因此，例如，如果我们知道某人有向我们撒谎的动机、有操纵我们的动机，我们就会更加警惕，更有能力检测他们的不诚实。同样，如果我们能够依靠人们的声誉，如果我对你的声誉一无所知，我对你所说的话就会比我非常了解你、知道你是个诚实的人时更加怀疑。但总的来说，当我们与遇到过或认识病理性撒谎者的人交谈，了解他们是如何知道这些人说谎的时候，我们发现他们说那些人会说出令人难以置信的
So how will your upcoming book online differ from the one that we at APA have already published? I found that to be quite accessible. I mean, I don't think you need to be a psychologist to read that, but what's going to be in your new book? Well, thanks for the kind words about the first book. We were hoping to make it accessible. But the difference in the second book is it doesn't focus on pathological liars. We certainly address pathological liars, but we look at people who lie prolifically or tell extremely consequential lies aside from pathological liars. So, you know, we're probably talking in a lot of cases about people who exhibit signs of psychopathy or antisocial personality disorder
事情，也就是说，他们提出的断言似乎根本不可能真正发生过，或者他们说的话前后矛盾。因此，例如，你知道，你刚才提到了乔治·桑托斯的例子，我相信他曾表示他的母亲在 9-11 袭击中去世，然后后来又声称她是在十年后去世的。因此，当我们看到信息存在前后矛盾时，这就可能是一个线索。所以实际上我们正在做的是寻找连贯性。我们在寻找证据，我们在寻找一个人的声誉地位。所有这些结合在一起可以为我们提供信息，让我们知道我们应该对谁保持怀疑，也许对谁可以更加信任。
or other personality disorders. But really what we're interested in is the people who tell the consequential lies or the extremely frequent lies where they develop a reputation as being a dishonest person. And we're looking at how do they develop into these types of big liars? What are the consequences of their big lying, both on themselves, on the people around them and on society more broadly? And then we examine ways for cultivating honesty, both in ourselves and the people around us. and we talk to a certain degree about different tactics we can use to avoid being duped. So what are you both working on now? I mean, what are the big questions that you're trying to answer at the moment?
或其他人格障碍。但实际上我们感兴趣的是那些说出重大谎言或极其频繁说谎的人，他们因此获得了不诚实之人的名声。我们正在研究他们是如何发展成为这类大话精的？他们大量说谎会对自己、身边的人以及更广泛的社会产生什么后果？然后，我们探讨培养诚实的方法，无论是在我们自己身上还是在我们周围的人身上，我们还在一定程度上讨论了我们可以用来避免被骗的不同策略。那么你们两个现在都在忙些什么？我的意思是，你们目前试图回答的重大问题是什么？
One of the things I kind of mentioned earlier that Chris and I with Victoria Tower are working on, digging deeper into the etiology. So onset and cause of pathological lying, you know, the big broad question all psychologists have, nurture how much of one or the other. And as a clinician, most clinicians want to understand etiology. So we're really digging into those questions that we don't know about how it develops and how it maintains. And then are there certain developmental trajectories that lead to a path of pathological
正如我刚才提到的，克里斯和我以及维多利亚·托尔（Victoria Tower）正在深入研究病因学。病理性说谎的起始和原因，你知道的，这是所有心理学家都有的一个宏观大问题：先天还是后天，各自占了多少？作为一名临床医生，大多数临床医生都想了解病因。因此，我们正在深入探究那些我们尚不清楚的发展和维持机制。此外，是否存在某些发展轨迹会导致病理性说谎的道路，
lying compared to normative lying? So that's where we're focusing a little more specifically right now with some of our research. Chris, as you want to add to that? Yeah, we're also doing a little bit of work on the motivators, what drives people to lie, especially what drives people to lie to excess. And so we can see that people don't lie randomly. They don't lie for no reason at all. If we see someone lying, there's some sort of an incentive that's driving them to lie. But we also, most people are balanced that with some disincentives to lie.
而这又与正常说谎有何不同？这就是我们目前在一部分研究中更加具体关注的地方。克里斯，你想补充一下吗？是的，我们还在做一些关于动机的研究，是什么驱使人们说谎，尤其是是什么驱使人们过度说谎。我们可以看到，人们不是随机说谎的。他们不会无缘无故地说谎。如果我们看到有人在说谎，背后一定有某种动因驱使着他们。但同时，大多数人也会用一些说谎的威慑因素来平衡这一点。
So, you know, if you are caught lying, it's certainly going to affect you reputational, which is going to hamper your ability to have the types of social relationships you desire. But then we also each have a moral sense of self that seems to curb most of our bad behavior. So we don't refrain from bad behavior simply because we're worried about getting caught. We refrain from it because we don't want to view ourselves as being awful people. And so trying to understand those complex motivations. that are behind people's decisions to lie, especially lie prolifically, or remain honest as another area of interest of ours. And then one other thing more recently, Chris has led,
所以，你知道，如果你被抓到说谎，这肯定会损害你的名誉，进而阻碍你建立自己期望的社会关系的能力。但除此之外，我们每个人都有一个道德自我感，这似乎能抑制我们大部分的不良行为。因此，我们克制不良行为不仅仅是因为担心被抓。我们克制是因为我们不想把视自己为糟糕的人。因此，试图理解那些隐藏在人们说谎决定背后的复杂动机，特别是那些习惯性说谎或保持诚实的决定，是我们感兴趣的另一个领域。最近还有一件事，由克里斯主导，
is developing an instrument to assess pathological lying more fully, an instrument that researchers and clinicians can use so we can assess pathological lying to answer some of these questions, get a little more accurate prevalence rate and study these things. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. I've found our conversation really interesting and enlightening, and I mean that honestly. We appreciate it. We enjoy it as well, honestly. Thank you so much for having us. It's been a great pleasure talking with you. You can find a link to pre-order the book, Big Liars, on APA's website, www.a.org, and just go there and search for big liars. Or if you can't wait, you can order. their current book, Pathological Lying, Theory, Research, and Practice, also on the APA website.
是开发一个更全面地评估病理性说谎的工具，一个研究人员和临床医生可以使用的工具，以便我们能够评估病理性说谎来回答其中一些问题，获得更准确的患病率并研究这些事情。嗯，我要感谢你们俩今天能来。我发现我们的对话非常有趣和启发人心，我是真心实意的。我们非常感激。我们也乐在其中，说真的。非常感谢邀请我们。与您交谈非常愉快。您可以在美国心理协会（APA）的网站 www.apa.org 上找到预订新书《大话精》（Big Liars）的链接，只需访问该网站并搜索“big liars”。或者如果您等不及了，也可以订购他们目前出版的书籍《病理性说谎：理论、研究与实践》（Pathological Lying: Theory, Research, and Practice），该书也可以在 APA 网站上找到。
For previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology, visit us at speakingofpsychology.org, or you can find us on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有关《心理学演讲》（Speaking of Psychology）往期节目，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org，或者您也可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请给我们留个评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学演讲》由李·维纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音响编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Kondayan）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。